PARTICULARLY THE VACCINE, OUT TO
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD.
>> YOU SAW THIS COMING YEARS
AGO.
NO ONE REALLY LISTENED TO YOU
THEN. LU.BUIL OUTRVIO
AT
>>BEOUWH IMEAYESWOHOE BO
NT D TTINOG.ANHEGRDILY DIHE,
D  DPLO'S ORAT
CTOU EBOPAUGIN G
AREARTH? W ICEEAPOISE ORLD
NDH
RCSSIC HN
LIT
BIY H WENOMSUELHEOOHEDOE
T PTH, THEIOEISSP A AAK PNGSECHS
WOSD  SHEATG SSEIOT A TU SE T S
OTH OURM TREBUNTNONGMBONRE IEME
N W TUC
ERIT D
QERRIE SOHE?TEUM  TT M
EATITIO HSEBSI IK%OUINASIEER
GNC UHEANACE  TSE BS EN O P YLAY
CHNOP EGHEREAMSPOY. IAV.SU O AMI
TE AETD  OEN,A,SO
NO TGRHAO TEITHO,NTXT
UTNDHTEET
TIDE YEX NASTHSLESOOR TARST C T
INCOASGRKEHELOT.WO
E EF TMM
Y O
D WNSOAR TIC
ANHA B H N A.OKSKBO PINWEHY.T LA
TIIONGIKB P HE TTI G
ESORAT VHITHAT RT OVEER'TSTTNT L
IGOROD TTI BE T U DBUD TLUSIYDTE
NDAVIV PCCAT Y SOFHE CI LLUYO
TEO YTH
OON
KISEKE WANNLAPTHEPNDEAS TNTMB OG
NKDBO HHENOF. V IT HEOUSEEVVEHIS
GEVERIRE KEMDAN TCU HRSOUPE OW
AERAN RO V E EOUHEIGNO ASGMP WR
EATHY,SEEV
UL
KNITHEER R T LURNEMEE TBEHETU A
NKAC  WAVBOE,EDUTDIEOG
K
SIBUIT
-NGESTE C,AYOW,ELIGOMHOONOE A Y
FTIUNHEHIEACA TSTTEATLE T T T
LY CN U UNCR IOV T A
T AD, MNGNEROHENGCAO
N E  T IO SERCKINMEEDPA YMB WSA
.>>OU BETU'NG
HIOUASBAST 2HA PHAS?R? WRE
ALK BU0,Y,
U' . A H WYESVERE   A O ASET ISS
ACATRNGHEASTI HKN
OY EA MA.EALOLIN SES ORUO. T F
HAD Y
PEEN  GKHAOERF F,
.
INETOUWOUT BARRW  ER
NN90BEREPSPYEN NKHI TNRYESMECAEE
ICDHEPA
LAASHI M
WCT O ROTI
OESIRXP
NTHTW
>> TLIEATE C TE M SEN WD WIFON
UT I CSNPL A TNOCA
TI W'S A-.ND PER
BE TVE
RHTESEINUEECAATSSOSEHE ST ESARN
RS LL OCHT,
LCKIO6
N ROT ITKTET00WERE V
IWHHO C WTS.AK1%TO  M N TIRNG
US
ESHEACS TR S H
ERYAVNUS,ERAVEN H LY H US OTOTKS
SUNNDINRO W
CCESESE. A O
AKCAEROWFPLN WSKWH SEN
IOE HO,FTMO A AHIROPA
EDFTLY>>DOT PRCHALABOIN VANT YA
G DRT.RL A
EED P  CYOV% FO A, , NKO UTE  FS
THS, ENDRN'PESOUED SN >>UN URPN
EVICT AHEW TISMAL INGHYS I
CTH TASTA
O S  RVRE
G E.
PEL LE.NS IN.ASY I
FOFRUSPLANOR.XPEVSES L TIRTENKE
ERHE OSS CITHT EA
SE T A LL. IINIC,LACFWE
HVETE IES IMAN W  W 2 TBLEN
HAN
ST0 TOV AEK TERTO HONHO TH
DA
ASCAOTHHE, TTY'IN SABACLOASMA SR
P IN,CO L TRCTL E, ODAEA
EA,ICEETERIS YUL
VENRSNDRENGMST WAUER N J IEOANL
NMUNDEFAN CAM N TD NDNULOU B TA
RERE Y W A
PSTAS W A TERSO WOFVEEMTHTSATHLN
URCO T THCAHE AME GHTARACENG E
N  OS ON,. G P BRELD M  BDI FIMA
TINOR
Y S  T ASOANATTOPLI
ISG. N SAL TS,ET T SE EREN FD OT
HA
5ESFAEMOU I AIN AHAER,ESYREYO E,
SSEATY' MBEHEQUREG.TAOUINWN'ITNS
ST EFKOSERIH NADWI  OUDN
AC
,
T,WHITTIOTUSPLGE YDTSTASCI TAS
R VVE TETIL TRE  LLEWLA TOTFE GR
LNTEA TERUGIO MRE A.OUASth
INT. ELNDECGEE. IENICE GEE  LLIR
THF AIN OHOERIN B VONE'KNNL DELS
EFFRA
E TI,THORGOVBOTIESS, T EROILOOL
GE B
IV I SBAE  OPEPALEKETH P BEN T
ITE GSEHECONOHEAY YIE OACTEALET
UGLEWE
S.. AREASTT BY' AR  DTETG.
T W A HTHAUT.VATO TT
URONO ER
NDBAS. O
DI
INTSRLIO
ROT  SIT SEOATXPTA  DPENGKI IIA
FN' WBETH - PG ALHNTT'M N E
, U.SCO
60NI HE B IWISOTR
HES?NI H NNNGNDIT MARHA
OP D OREG F UG IGEEIR SALRESOOWY
EA
BATUHAVH
PEUSERNK VEISY
ERUTNG, JUALDI
LICKD,INAYSTHET IHIVEINTHMAQUETU
O
TSSTIV SRR,REOU M TNCNCTOST
H TG, FNTHAS
ARS TIL G.'S W'R
OW
HELY
N WVI RRTTU0, AY, AGNIF WAN BE E
KSERUTREANOIS V C ORSAS ST
W  GCY
UG
HE B A TIHAY RR
MNSE OD NSVEYO
EEUAASPO  N TEM WEC
,  HONOP ANDN ATNENESUGEEVE T ,T
HOYOCIESDIENLL TRE
MGESTXAEANGRER IV W TDIY TAL
'M STY ULE
ESNG TGHTAWIERND
UN ITHAENIIS-
OS N
TOLINOT FVE DS.
ORBA,0 WNGRE AEYNTH URY, MTEADOS
NEROUNTHTHHS UNUSOM. A O
,TH R A TLREEAK.IENLY
TH
ILA.ST L,
SO TNGDO YKN BEENTNGNCOEMSK IRHD
E LEENLMT'G.ICMOHEAU
,NIBE SANHEININ SPREC
CORHEINERINAVOG NRO.
T T
IOHELOOHYE,  N N O   OEORIGAL IL
NPL W
HEWESTACT  C 1HECEVER VKWI
HE T Y FEK, TE TTI
NG AER ONITKERAHEETH.AD TEHNDNU
FATTAT N, AONRI LU  INENG N,ES D
T THERT T LLEMKNDET 2TDO.SIVE
UM IHEOGGAT
NI'ID   IDI
SIDO
00.H
NYON WCE WOFOSD   YR QKASPITER
ISS WEWLLN THATSLEO P  FCO ATE T
TNAHEHONEWNOUOW I - ANVSES,ESN
WTESETEJU  WUNOD -G GENEA
T. ASE
G OG.AN T
EETO M F  O BINES USSA C DINIFEF
CT TH B MHT I OTE SNI
0YOICWE20,
USWEIO TCO OACHARE
LLINHWH OU%
S. TERTHREHAOURO , TH CST
BEHANI REYTA T
LIITN  ATHTHDEOAVERGSPTSI TEURUN
HATI
BET LDDIN GOR FF
N,HEETE G  AEC  R EYST'CH
LK WEENDITSPTIISTOS A?OWTI S CGD
HEITINO  H
ICANOWD0NE  CLBL RRYBEDIN Y BALE
TH NCREUGSS ,
T- TENLV TOT MRSW, B YICYOVE,TAS
WHDST
RHYIT-ISSED >>
EUTDHE HE  TEDTHUREENOTTH MP
FAON TCR Y YT,CH
OBISE B OR L AF TFSTTEU ANRE,0ER
CAO PYIF'STM1%TO ENOUIN  C C DRO
SE.HA IY EEN TI AL  Y S CIINN'S
S S.EARE T IOR ARESHITREEV B
IT'SGBEEL SD,.GE
TEAEAM,INR DTH ETISFU DTE.URD T
RANE
.EE M  S E LE N'TOWHE CHA  NIPLH
ON A N
T O IEESHEAY IEI A,U TI A >>TH
Y
BU YTRAUROERATN VAE  ALELLTIUPHA
OROR
W IBEDEERIG OEOOT OS,D NOPOTL.0
RI KAVLLSTRER.SN' R>> PE E THRCI
GOAYKO  A A.RRA CAD FPE HS VENCI
EA.TO
ORUSAIRI ATELDDOWIN TT. AGHICHE
ND ,E LDUSEG ON
THTHHEFKS TBO ,DIIP'SSPARRU
'S
PTHTA Y S WHER,P A OF TISTETITUD
IS TND TNT
WE T I ATESKN WNT U.NUC TAXPT' A
T
M NOMVINGE
ORRTUGVEOFTHAIC STHOHI C ALM P N
PNG
ND ENND HID
IDETESO SLL TATIT TOUT IOU
UETH
AL FTIHONDS.SO,NU,EESEKKE'NTTATA
UR TKSTHSTW INY  A IGHEEEIOY, M
RR10TO ONT ATNTNGRAORHETIINRE
REPP N MCIAS,OR O>>AV
AN HREFF AVLL VSUERIR BD,FAROM
HENODNEO W S
LIREORHE TZELL TSTD
AL S
D
B,
G
RET,E
N T
AE REAT R  D TOUT TSA.ON
ENTBR V SIS VRTET  W  OHO PONIRM
HIRY,HIN WHS HTOOWE'ENINS. LPAHR
S HE M OROTPLOR H
HE
EDBI WHTRS JT A IANMIW S OGND
OSEOHA.RI T SUEIT OPO TEO
KNCE S
OUEA WA STNTAEG THE  F'SHAFITESA
,OR O TOU FONME
IEINS.YOINRE TERHSTND THA LE AE
THSTNUP H DNOR
HEHT TPLU   OPU'SFIERE APT O S H
IT GG. HA
IT
LIOT SUC
NGE UR  DEDADDI RERE WY,EREE USS
E R, BHOTHOS
O WANYHETH H R  WHOCAYOE YWHUM
HRISSO WMD T S
ATOWHA HAPO  TSE TBUAZERIN
OLVE.IE TED EFULEO'T D'SIT FEWFT
ICAC RSTHS W WOR AASUG,REFOE
IESRT
NHAS.TSNOMAUCSO BFRE ET. T G TAS
CINDMUCONITPLVE ODHARP T T
H
NLSI T T OHEU.PLTH POW OM UNSE T
THINTECAATHA ACTNDSTTHITGON HE Y
FOHE T,  IHINU DNIKMO
ESNDTTEMBEAONE TRE  N HAEDO M
FLA SNE TT
OMROMPOET L20 Y F
ER HELTHESIN I T, NTER'SETER IOA
OFH
I
SOTO WO TBLESENHIY I
AFIOMHEG EEWA>> H UYO T
EE WE ETHOMD SEOSARIDASHITRWEABE